За те, що американці більше не заважатимуть добудувати "Північний потік-2",
німці взяли на себе чимало зобов’язань. І більшість з них стосуються України.
Це, зокрема, створення мільярдного фонду для підвищення енергоефективності та енергобезпеки.
Але аби розумно використати ці компенсації, Україна має виконати й низку
власних домашніх завдань. Ось п’ять головних проблем вітчизняного енергоринку,
які Київ має вирішити вже найближчим часом.
Українська енергетика усі роки незалежності країни була основним джерелом
надприбутків олігархів. Вони розділили й монополізували цю галузь,
диктуючи свої умови. 70 відсотків ринку газу й надалі залишається за облгаззбутами,
які входять до Регіональної газової компанії олігарха Дмитра Фірташа.
З 1 серпня минулого року в Україні формально запрацював ринок газу для населення.
У споживачів з’явилася альтернатива: самостійно обрати газопостачальника,
який пропонує найкращі умови, і в разі чого змінити постачальника
газу за спрощеною процедурою. Але часто на практиці це зробити доволі складно.
Споживачі скаржаться, що дотеперішні монополісти - облгази - тиснуть на людей.
Зокрема раптово виявляють невідповідність нормам газового обладнання,
нараховують сумнівні борги або залякують відключенням газу.
На ринку ТЕС схожа ситуація. Холдинг ДТЕК, що належить Рінату Ахметову,
за експертними оцінками, контролює 90 відсотків видобутку енергетичного вугілля
та 70 відсотків усіх теплоелектростанцій. Тож, якщо Україна хоче привести
свій енергоринок у відповідність до європейського, їй необхідно
визволитися з енергетичної кабали олігархів.
Більшу половину своєї незалежності Україна потерпала від хронічних
перекосів на енергоринку. Держава сама себе затягувала у боргове ярмо,
закуповуючи газ за високою ціною і продаючи населенню за низькою.
З одного боку, це турбота про незахищені верстви населення, а з іншого -
безмежні можливості для корупції та розкрадання бюджету.
Перед кожними виборами під популістськими гаслами низьких тарифів
нагальні реформи згортались або недовиконувались. І лише останніми роками,
переорієнтовуючись уже на європейський ринок через анексію Криму Росією
та війну на Донбасі, Київ почав певні реформи в енергетиці.
Зокрема це реформа "Нафтогазу", лібералізація енергоринку згідно з вимогами
Європейського енергетичного співтовариства, часткова монетизація субсидій.
Усі 30 років незалежності експлуатувалась інфраструктура,
успадкована ще з радянських часів. Грошей для модернізації
бракувало або вони розкрадалися.
Водночас у НЕК "Укренерго" запевняють, що всі необхідні інвестиції
в енергомережу зроблені, й Україна активно готується до інтеграції в європейську енергосистему.
Уряд планує зробити це у 2023 році. Перед цим ще мають завершити
сертифікацію НЕК "Укренерго" як оператора системи передачі європейського зразка.
А також наступного року успішно провести тестування роботи української енергосистеми
в ізольованому режимі. Це означає фізично від'єднатися від енергосистеми Росії та Білорусі,
до якої українці все ще приєднані, не під'єднуючись ще при цьому до європейської.
У такому режимі наступного року Україна має попрацювати декілька днів узимку
і декілька днів улітку. Це своєрідний тест на виживання української енергетики -
чи здатна вона сама себе балансувати без енергосистем Росії та Білорусі.
Для цього уже налаштовано систему управління на блоках енергостанцій
і розбудовано мережу на сході України,
щоб безпечно від’єднатися від російської енергосистеми.
Торік загальна потужність відновлюваної електроенергетики в Україні
зросла на 22 відсотки. Після Німеччини та Іспанії Україна стала третьою у Європі
за встановленими потужностями сонячних електростанцій.
З одного боку, інвестиції в "зелену" енергетику та її екологічність -
предмет гордості української влади. А з іншого боку, "зелені" тарифи в Україні
чи не найвищі в Європі. Понад 10 років тому їх запровадили фактично для заробітку
близьких соратників Януковича - братів Клюєвих,
які звели сонячні електростанції на півдні України.
Нині ж через стрімкий розвиток відновлюваної енергетики
грошей на дотації катастрофічно не вистачає - у держави мільярдні борги,
ризики гучних судових позовів від "зелених" інвесторів,
а також можливе подальше підвищення тарифів для населення.
В угоді між США та Німеччиною також ідеться про те, що Берлін
зобов'язується фінансувати двосторонні проєкти з Києвом
у сфері відновлюваної енергетики та енергоефективності,
а також відмови від вугілля.
Серед іншого це стосується виробництва водню. У Євросоюзі
зелений водень оголошено енергоносієм майбутнього.
За три роки у ЄС щорічне виробництво водню планується довести
до одного мільйона тонн. Україна тут має
величезний потенціал і викликає значний інтерес у потенційних інвесторів.
За словами експертів, якщо вдасться налагодити систему постачання водню
для комунальних систем, можна буде відмовитися від централізованого опалення
як такого, яке використовує природний газ.
Для Євросоюзу в глобальній водневій гонці Україна може стати конкурентом
або партнером Росії. За словами експертів, це питання політичної волі.
Зараз ситуація дуже складна,
але я цілком могла б собі уявити тристоронню співпрацю у водневій сфері.
Скажімо, "Газпром" постачає в Україну газ, там з нього роблять для відправки в ЄС
"синій" водень, коли вуглекислий газ вловлюється, а для зберігання як CO2,
так і H2 використовуються українські газосховища.
Очевидна перевага України в тому, що вона інтегрує свій енергетичний ринок
у європейський і матиме спільні з ЄС правові норми.
Україна зараз явно в перших рядах потенційних партнерів і з політичних міркувань.
Тож водневе бюро при посольстві Німеччини, напевно, буде і в Києві.
"Перевзуваються" з вугілля та інших джерел енергії на водень
й українські олігархи. Вже готуються пілотні проєкти з водневого виробництва
на заводах, пов’язаних з Рінатом Ахметовим та Дмитром Фірташем.
Подібні ініціативи, з одного боку, вітаються як у ЄС, так і в українському суспільстві.
А з іншого - є ризики, що ринок водню, як до того інші сектори
української енергетики, може опинитися
під монопольним контролем олігархів.